[Music]
Gregor Mendel's experiments laid the
foundation of modern-day genetics we
have seen so far that Mendel crossed a
purple flowered plant with a white
flowered plant he then collected the
seeds and grew new plants from them
astonishingly he found that all the
offsprings had purple colored flowers
now on crossing these plants among
themselves Mendel surprisingly obtained
three purple flower plants and one white
flower plant how could this be possible
moreover what could be the probable
reasons for this the first set of
results were that all the plants in the
first or f1 generation were with purple
colored flowers here the term f1
indicates the first filial generation in
this case he considered color of the
flower as a character did he cross pea
plants having other characters - yes he
considered all the other characters like
plant height seed color and so on and
then he found that only one character is
expressed in the f1 generation for
instance he crossed a pea plant having
round seats with the one having wrinkled
seeds in the f1 generation he obtained
all the plants having only round seeds
it implied that the offsprings are
similar to only one of the parents and
do not have any resemblance with the
other and this was seen for all the
characters now getting back to our
example of flower color Mendel obtained
all the plants with purple colored
flowers in the f1 generation but this
wasn't the case in the next stem when
the offsprings from this f1 generation
were crossed one plant out of the four
had traits just like the original parent
that was considered that means in this
case one out of the four had white
colored flowers and three had purple
colored flowers
with this he concluded that characters
are passed from one generation to the
other
with the current knowledge we have we
know that this is due to the passing of
genes however it was not known back then
Mendel named these as factors so it was
believed that there are factors which
carry these traits from one generation
to the other but what about the
disappearance of the trait in one
complete generation in the f1 generation
the trait of white colored flowers was
not seen at all this was explained by
Mendel in a very efficient manner
he explained that in organisms like the
green peas one factor is always
expressed and it's super past the
presence of the other factor we call
these factors as genes or alleles now we
will have a detailed look at what genes
mean in our upcoming parts but for now
let's focus on Mendel's work in today's
terms Mendel said that some genes are
always expressed irrespective of the
other these are called dominant genes
the others which are suppressed are
referred to as recessive genes so why
did the recessive genes not express
themselves in the f1 generation and how
did they get expressed in the f2
generation let's understand this with
the help of a theoretical explanation of
this cross let's consider letter P
written in uppercase as the allele that
is factor in Mendel's terms for the
purple colored flower and the white
colored flower will be represented with
the allele P written in lowercase
now the first cross included purple
flower plant and a white flood plant so
this is how we can represent this
crossing any idea why have we used the
letter P twice here it's simple the
green B plant is a diploid plant
what does diploid mean
we have always come across the saying
that humans have 23 pairs of chromosomes
that's because the chromosomes in us are
always in pairs each set has one
chromosome from each parent this is
nothing but the diploid nature so when
organisms have two sets of chromosomes
they are referred to as diploid
organisms getting back to green peas
there are two sets of genes in it that
is why we use the letter twice to
represent both the allelic forms so here
we be written in uppercase will
represent the purple color of flowers
while P P written in lowercase will
represent the white color of flowers now
in this cross the gametes which are
nothing but the reproductive cells will
be formed like this and the cross will
yield us this result how this
combination this one then this one and
this is the last one these are the four
possible combinations now as you can see
here PP indicates that the offspring has
one dominant and one recessive allele in
such a case the plants will have only
purple flowers as the presence of one
dominant gene is enough to express the
trait that is why all the plants have
purple colored flowers in the f1
generation now can you guess why the
ratio 3 to 1 is obtained in the f2
generation let's find that out with the
help of a similar theoretical cross here
we take any two random plants from the
f1 generation crossing these two or even
by carrying out the selfing process in a
similar fashion gives us this result now
as we can see here these 3 offsprings
have at least one dominant gene that is
the reason why each of these is a purple
flower plant now in this case
what the genes are recessive that means
no gene to dominate the trait as a
result the plant expresses the recessive
trait that is white colored flowers this
was the simplest way to explain Mendel's
results dominant genes are those which
are expressed in both homozygous and
heterozygous forms on the other hand
recessive genes are those which can be
expressed only when present in
homozygous form hold on any idea what do
we mean by homozygous and heterozygous
we know that the term homo means same
and hetero means different so homozygous
means the set of genes are same both
either dominant or both recessive for
example P P and P P are both homozygous
forms heterozygous is exactly opposite
of this
it simply means both the forms are
different so here P P represents the
heterozygous form one dominant one
recessive so the dominant alleles are
expressed in both homozygous and
heterozygous forms wild recessive
alleles can be expressed when present
only in the homozygous forms this was
just an introduction to Mendel's
experiments let's have a look at one
more example and a few more terms in
genetics in the next part we have seen
how the cross of the character like
flower color is carried out in this part
let's get introduced to a few more
interesting terms in genetics but before
that let's understand the cross of one
more character and get thorough with it
before beginning any such experiment we
need to make sure that the parents
selected are homozygous in nature so
let's say we wish to cross two organisms
with some trait named a the dominant
bomb should ideally be a a both in
uppercase
while the recessive form has to be a
both in lowercase
now the recessive form will definitely
be homozygous why yes we note that the
recessive character is expressed only
when it's in the homozygous form but the
dominant character can have both the
sets of alleles so a in uppercase as
well as a a one in upper and the other
in lowercase can give us a dominant case
so it could be homozygous or
heterozygous now how are we supposed to
know whether the organism considered for
crossing is homozygous or heterozygous
for a particular character for this we
have the concept of your lines
pure lines are nothing but the
descendants obtained after in reading
for several generations confused don't
be it's easy to understand this with an
example let's say we have this
particular breed of dogs both these have
genes for a good coat on the skin
sissie so both these dogs may have the
genes CC both in uppercase or CC that is
one and upper and the other in lowercase
on crossing these two dogs we get these
offsprings clearly the genes are passed
to this generation now on crossing any
of the two dogs from this same progeny
we get these offsprings that means again
the same set of genes is passed to the
next generation imagine this is done for
a few more generations what will be the
result the progeny at the end will have
these genes conserved but notice
something interesting as we keep
crossing the individuals in the same
family the chances of obtaining the
homozygous form is enhanced this process
of crossing individuals from the same
family
called inbreeding and offsprings
obtained after in reading several
generations are called pure lines one of
the advantages of using pure lines while
beginning the experiment is to have an
assurance that the organism is
homozygous even for the dominant trait
now let's focus back on the cross we
were about to carry out this time let's
consider the character stem height in
the pea plant here we take a tall and a
dwarf plant both these are pure lines on
crossing the parental generation we get
these offsprings in the f1 generation
now what will happen when we cross these
two plants from the f1 generation it
will give us these results take a moment
to go through this so what we get is
three tall plants and one dwarf plant
isn't this the same ratio that Mendel
obtained when flower color was
considered as the character yes it is he
had obtained three purple and one white
flower in the f2 generation similarly
here we get three tall and one Dwarfs
plant now that we've had a good idea
about crossing let me introduce two new
terms to you trust me they are very
simple to understand the two terms are
phenotypic ratio and genotypic ratio in
this case the phenotypic ratio is three
to one that is three tall plants and one
dwarf plant and the genotypic ratio is
one to two to one as we can see one
plant is homozygous for the tall trait
these two are heterozygous and this one
is homozygous for the recessive trait
dwarf any idea what these terms mean
let's understand them first and then
proceed with understanding the ratios
the features that can be seen or
observed by us externally are called
phenotypes
fino is a prefix that indicates an
observable characteristic we could
clearly see in this case three are tall
and one is a Dwarfs plant
hence the phenotypic ratio is threes to
one what about the genotypic ratio let's
take an example here if we look at this
tall guy what can we say about his jeans
this tall guy can have the jeans TT both
in uppercase or TT one in upper and the
other in lowercase we can't really
predict it so just by having a glance we
can't really guess if the individual is
homozygous or heterozygous for height as
the character so the features of the
genetic level which cannot be observed
are called genotypes in simple words the
physical expression of the genes giving
rise to the particular observable traits
can be termed as phenotype on the other
hand genotype can be defined as the set
of genes that give rise to a particular
trait that is the genetic makeup of an
organism so the trait that's visible to
us is the phenotype and what genes the
organism has for that trait is the
genotype for example if this boy has
black eyes then the eye color seen by us
is the boys phenotype and the genes that
he has inherited from his parents which
are not seen by us are a part of his
genotype now getting back to our
experiment how do we understand the
genotypic ratio well as we can see we
have one homozygous tall plant two
heterozygous tall plants and one
homozygous dwarf plant so the genotypic
ratio is one to two to one now we are
all well-versed with the crosses and
also a few important terms in genetics
take a moment to go through these
important terms once
let's now move ahead and understand
Gregor Mendel's experiments further so
far we've seen how Mendel crossed plants
and studied one character at a time do
you think he always crossed only a
single character at a time no after he
completed crossing all the characters
individually he crossed two characters
at a time followed by three and so on
the cross involving one character at a
time is called monohybrid cross so
whatever we've learned so far was a
monohybrid cross and the ratio obtained
after the cross is nothing but a
monohybrid ratio how is the dihybrid
cross that is a cross involving two
characters at a time carried out there
and what about the dihybrid ratio let's
get to know that in the next part
[Music]